so yeah like is this the first time
you've shown your face on camera is this
the face reveal
um for a long time
uh no you should your face right
what when when you did the like eating
noodles thing oh yeah was that was that
in your mom's basement yeah it was my
mom's face okay yeah so that was like a
day before
not even a day like i was gonna i was
gonna have to take the plane within like
three hours all right and i'm like going
to ax that's when i met you guys oh oh
okay
and i'm like well if i'm gonna go i need
at least some people to like you know
recognize me i guess yeah yeah yeah so i
was like what can i need people to
recognize me
no club no it just makes it more fun
yeah yeah
especially when you have other creative
friends yeah yeah you're that guy yeah
yeah too fast i didn't know what you
looked like when i met you yeah me
neither i just knew about you yeah yeah
because i was just like
um
i would suggest anyone who's starting
youtube don't like hide your face like
just show it
yeah just show it right off the bat
because the expectation was like so high
all right
nothing i could have done would have
like been able to uh
deal with it so i was just like i'm just
going to record a shitty ass video of me
eating ramen
and i'm just going to [ __ ] upload it
yeah you got like the hypercam logo in
the corner yeah well i photoshopped that
myself
yeah well what i loved about that face
reveal video was that
the room was so dark and the quality was
so [ __ ] you couldn't see your face
you had to like squint being like he's
in there somewhere i think he's white i
think he's white i think he's
white yeah it's just like a i guess that
was when i was like you know i was
presentable now i just got fatter and
i'm like [ __ ] i don't want to show my
face anymore i i especially during
covert i was like [ __ ] i'm fat i'm gonna
hide all right they're flying man you
look fine
and like what did you get like a lot of
people coming up to you at ax during
that time because i realized i never
really asked you about that oh decent
amount it's like the the thing is like
like i said like my hypercam was like
very hard to see
so sometimes it'd be like hey and then
you already had like the [ __ ] you
know when they they're like have you
seen this man and it's always like one p
footage of like the crap
happening that was like literally your
face is real it's funny because i did
have blue hair no okay i didn't pick up
in the
yeah you did have blue hair well because
you were wearing your hat as well right
yeah we you uploaded on instagram like a
picture yeah with me and i was so drunk
that day that when you did that i looked
at it and i was like i don't remember
this
because it was at the faku party and
like i hadn't watched your face reveal
video at the time yeah because you know
i was obviously getting prepared for ax
and [ __ ] um
and then yeah i was just kind of like
hanging out and then i just hear like
hey joey
and you just like talked to connor yeah
yeah
talk to joey yeah and you like ran over
and i was like and you know you came
over he's like yeah what's up man and i
was like who is this guy
but then i heard the voice and i was
like oh dude which reminds me that
that's sort of that's so crazy the voice
i don't
you're very iconic
before i even did the face reveal on my
channel yeah yeah i went to chipotle in
maine
and i went up and i went to get my order
i was i was like scuffed i had a full
beard i had like i was in my pajamas
yeah i was like could i get like a
large burrito
steak right and the the lady the cashier
was uh well the burrito lady was like
are you a youtuber and i was like
no
like because i was too embarrassed
yeah yeah yeah your way of talking is
very noticeable yeah i feel bad for like
corpse husband like he can't even go out
and be like is that corn yeah
when you hide your face like
expectations too high it it sucks a lot
of poo poo
thank you for that
i thought you liked fruit
i like
pooping no because like because like the
first time dyson i interacted he made an
animation for me like way back when you
had like 50 subs or something oh yeah i
was very desperate yeah
and i didn't know how to talk to
big creators yeah so i was like do i
talk to him like in a friendly way or do
i do like business or do i do like
whatever yeah and i was like asking my
dad i'm like how do i how do i interact
with like a big youtuber or whatever
so i tried different things and i was
like this is [ __ ] cringe like the
last email i said was so cringy i really
i didn't remember oh good because you
didn't reply to it and i'm like oh
because i remember when you made that
animation for me and you obviously you
know like put your narrative oh and it
got demonetized yeah i got demonetized
but like but i remember like because you
put your narration into it as well right
and like uh your friend sen's narration
was in that as well yeah and you know
and i was like man this guy's voice is
like
really unique like it's like i don't
know it was something about
the way
you speak i don't know how do you
describe his voice like it's
it's like it's
interesting inflections yeah it's
different words you know i don't have
enough descriptors to like be able to
describe someone's voice your tone of
voice is you know pretty standard but
it's your inflection yeah voice like
when you talk it's like very like i go
high like this yeah i don't know just
don't do that
what i i remember
i didn't really
i mean i was okay with my voice usually
and then i had an ex-girlfriend that
said like my voice made me sound dumb
and i like took that to heart i was like
am i actually like do i sound dumb
then but later like on youtube like the
comments would be like i love your voice
i'm like yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm
okay
no no you're fine yeah yeah yeah
it's a very unique quality that i think
you know you've obviously used to your
strengths yeah obviously it's a very
good thing
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's how
like your story yeah yeah exactly and
it's like it's like you can hear dyer's
video when you hear it yeah exactly it's
like immediately like yeah that's like
especially like neutral
it's only an advantage if you don't show
your face as well because like that
means your voice is so distinct and it
helps set you apart from any other
person who doesn't show their face you
know showing her face is a little
sketchy because it's like will this
affect my
channel does this affect how people see
me probably not though really i mean
because i i didn't really if you're
tender if you're doing something
concerning or something that people
think is widely like not accepted yeah
you know you're doing like sexual things
a lot of people unfortunately they judge
you quite harshly yeah that's like
youtubers isn't it i guess a lot of them
just want it for the privacy though
right yeah yeah it's not that that's the
show
i guess if you're like if you're being
you wouldn't be that sexual if your face
was maybe shown i don't know yeah i mean
the point is is it there are a lot of
reasons why
my immersion my immersion yeah yeah
i feel like i've done this so long
though that like like [ __ ] it i mean
like i think like you mentioned
youtubers but i think just every every
v2 is different they've cultivated a
different kind of audience as well so
very much toxic
yeah yeah so it very much depends
on the kind of audience you cultivate
and you know a lot of youtubers have
shown their faces yeah yeah yeah just
also don't want to show their face which
is like obviously like you that wine
that's totally fine yeah yeah because
it's the [ __ ] internet right and you
know especially nowadays privacy is a
[ __ ] massive thing on the internet
where i feel like a lot of people are
entitled to know what someone looks like
you know like obviously you know they
might go to chipotle and get recognized
by their voice but like that's something
they just have to like figure out yeah
like i feel because that's their choice
yeah like i said like you mentioned
corpse husband i feel so sorry for
corpses because there's like [ __ ]
stories no that's just like [ __ ] that
sounds like there's like [ __ ] people
who like i basically like hiring private
detectives like find out what he looks
like and [ __ ] right
i'm just like oh my god i can't imagine
like that chick who got a tattoo of the
waveform of him breathing into the mic
oh my god yeah yeah how'd you even like
handle that kind of like go out
and like talk
yeah yeah yeah like he probably has to
just say like he just has to write on
notes
get a voice changer yeah burrito please
[Laughter]
yeah have you like ever thought about
incorporating your your face into your
content more or less let's just just you
want to join the first super game be
more casual i guess
faster but yeah
i'll think about i definitely want to
try different things though was it
animating um drawing and stuff streaming
or anything like that i do want to do
streaming yeah i have a i made a
youtuber model myself yeah cool um it
was very hard to learn it was it was
like
was it 2d live
yeah yeah live 2d yeah yeah i did it all
on the stream yeah i did it it took me
like i don't know like
a week or two
oh it only took me long because i was
like taking my sweet time but yeah yeah
yeah yeah and then i got another model
going on yeah
we'll play around with that and then i
mean if i show myself on camera enough
like people get used to it and i'll be
like okay i can show my space yeah yeah
like every time i'm like doing stuff
with connor or you guys are you know i'm
on camera it's like that's what dice
looks like well what the [ __ ] well you
know
yeah i guess yeah i guess it'll just
take a bit of time for your audience to
like get used to it yeah but once they
once they're used to it i don't think
there'll be any problems at all yeah i
mean like even though i showed like my
face at the end of like every one of my
videos it was only like after i started
being on trash taste that people like oh
that's what he looks like and i'm just
like [ __ ] i've been showing my
face for years you know everyone just
clicked off before the end so nobody saw
before